this is jocko podcast number 311 with
echo charles and me jocko willing good
evening echo good evening
june 6 1944
d-day
largest seaborn invasion in history
almost 7 000 ships and landing vessels
almost 200 000 naval personnel and 150
000 ground troops
attacking the heavily fortified beaches
of the nazis atlantic wall
in france
in doing so allied forces suffered over
ten thousand casualties
including four thousand four hundred and
fourteen
killed in action
it was a brutal assault
but the beachhead was secured
however the fighting was not over
far from it
there was
much fighting to be done
the fight through
the villar's bokage the assault on the
city of kane and sherborg
the battle to seize
the village of saint lo
the fight to close the fellas gap the
liberation of paris the advance to the
rhine
operation market garden in the battle of
arnhem
battles at moore burge
overloon
the hurtkin forest
and all the way
to the battle of the bulge in the
ardennes forest
the battle of the bulge the largest
battle fought by americans in world war
ii december 1944 through january 1945
included a million allied troops 500 000
americans
resulted in more than 47 000 wounded
over 23 000 missing and 19 000
killed in action
but in the battle of the bulge once
again victory
was achieved
and eventually victory in europe was
achieved and then japan
and that victory was achieved by what is
now known as the greatest generation
and it is an absolute honor
for us tonight to have one of those men
here with us
a man that landed on d-day
and fought all the way to the battle of
the bulge
his name is mr jake larson also known as
papa jake
and he is here with us sir
thank you for coming it is an honor to
have you here well it's an honor to be
here
[Music]
thank you very much for the introduction
and i
don't think i'm any sp one special
but
of all the people i was with
and i started
at a young age
when i was 15 i joined the national
guard and
i
i was in
camp claiborne louisiana
for nearly a year when the japanese hit
pearl harbor
so
i go back a few few years
and
as i look back
every person that i was with
in three different units
company f 135th infantry regiment
company
h
headquarters company 135th
infantry regiment
and
fifth corps
every person i was with
is gone
why i'm here now
maybe in
a few days i'm going to be 99 years old
99 years i can't believe it myself
i don't have aches and pains like other
people have
no arthritis no
stiff
thing
i i get up out of bed
i'm wide awake
it's crazy
i think my my life is governed from
above
and i i thank those up there
who who are doing this to me who are
sitting with me right now
i thank them for helping me
well sir um
you said you said you don't think you're
anything special which i guess we could
argue at that point but i'm not here to
argue with you sir however
you have to admit that you are lucky and
in fact you did admit it you have a book
that you wrote which is called the
luckiest man in the world and i think
you're definitely in the in the running
for it
well i i appreciate that
but
you have to read the book i can't sit
here and start telling you
how lucky i am
but
even before d-day
a month before d-day
if if anything was happening that had to
do with exercises
i i intended
firing every kind of weapon because i
came from the infantry
so uh
that was down to land's end they were
shooting 50 caliber
air water-cooled machine guns at towed
targets
and
then
that british had this little exercise
that slept in sands
and uh
they were going to greet us with live
fire
pretty interesting there that
i was one chosen from g3 to go down
there a sergeant
and
i was with others
from the landing
there was 400 of us on this landing ship
and and this was
we'll get to that part of the story but
this what you're talking about this
exercise at slapped and sands this was
just a pr preparatory
event to get ready for d-day
and yet where you were doing this
training there was enemy there there was
enemy enemy vessels
there was two e-boats germany boats came
in there
and sank two of those landing ship tanks
right alongside of me
and shot up the the armed guard on top
of the one i was in
and we had no air
we were
400 of us laying there on the floor
suffering from
diesel gas
and
vomiting
i don't know how we
made it back to plymouth
england
but when we got to plymouth
a full bird colonel came out called us
to attention and swore us to secrecy
we could not even discuss this with our
superior officers when we got back
and this
i i didn't know anything about this
or tell anyone about it for 40 years
40 years the british
brought it up
and
people started calling me a liar because
nothing like that ever happened
well i was there
i was there it happened to me
and
i found out that
the
400 of those guys that
had
sank there were 795
casualties there 400
was from the fourth
infantry division which was supposed to
land
alongside of us
on d-day
it
it's un unbelievable to think about now
no mention of these guys
they're all buried over in england
and they were put
put on on the record as being
lost
come coming to shore on d-day
crazy
and that's one of the the many stories
you have in this book and and the book
is is is a phenomenal book and
i wanted to kind of go back in time a
little bit and just talk about where you
came from and and read a little bit from
the book
um
and i'll i'll skip around so everyone
that's out there if you you have to get
the whole book i'm only going to read
some little pieces of it today but just
wanted to talk to you about some of the
things that you talk about in the book
um you say here
my birthday in december 1922 had a huge
effect on my life because i was younger
than most of my classmates who were born
earlier in the year all this meant
however was that i learned how to get
things done
now you grew up with seven
seven brothers and sisters yes you had
todd earl evan leo merle
eleanor and bobby
and you note in here you say i remember
asking leo how i was born
and he told me that a crow [__] on a
fence post and the sun hatched me out
whenever i saw crow i wondered if it was
the one responsible for my birth
living on a farm i saw plenty of
chickens hatch so the story made sense
to me
so i think uh your brother leo had you
fooled for a little while
well well he was 10 years older than me
and when you when you're five and
somebody is is uh 15
you look for somebody that
is gonna
enlighten you
indeed
so you your parents started off on a
homestead in south dakota and you talk
about that someone here but then
eventually
um
grandma larson who lived in hope
minnesota wrote to my father and her
husband's after her husband's death
asking if he could move
to hope to run the farm my parents
packed their bags once again and moved
to 240 acre farm
bertha got 80 acres and we got the rest
the downstairs included the living room
along with paw and mother's bedrooms and
the kitchen which had a wood stove
equipped with burners an oven and a 30
gallon reservoir
you say paw's bedroom was off the
kitchen and mom's room was by the living
room they didn't sleep in the same bed
but managed to have eight kids anyways
and then all the kids rooms were
upstairs
yeah yes yeah
and you you went through i know we're uh
going through a pandemic right now but
you went through the
or your parents began running the farm
after the flu
pandemic of 1918.
and that that took my
only living
grandparent
at the time it was my my grandmother
and
grandmother larson
her husband my grandfather
died in his 40s
he came in
the city came in from the barn
complaining that he had a
pain in his stomach sharp pain and they
thought a horse kicked him in the
stomach
and
i
was a victim of appendicitis my oldest
brother was a bit so it was appendicitis
that
killed him
it broke broke
and i i went through that same thing
so
so growing up on the farm
uh you say life on the farm was not easy
it was plain hard work every member of
the family had chores we'd get up at
about 6 a.m drink hot cocoa then do
chores like milking cows carrying feed
for the cattle cleaning the stalls
adding in the new straw separating milk
and cream the milk went to the hogs and
the cream went to the house we poured
cream into cans dropping them into the
well to keep them cool we milked 30 to
32 cows by hand every morning and night
i was about six years old when i started
milking cows
yeah
it's a crazy life
but we didn't think anything about it it
was our life
and the neighbors were living the same
way we were so it was pretty natural
and
we didn't have
a lot of extra
money for good clothes
if our overhauls got a hole in it from
wear or from tear
my mother was an excellent seamstress
and sewing machine up
operator
by
everything done with the pedal sewing
machine
so
so you had all that going on plus you
had turkeys geese pigs
horses ducks and you planted wheat and
corn and and barley and oats and alfalfa
and soybeans tomatoes potatoes carrots
turnips yeah they had everything going
on
we lived out of fruit jars
that that was
that was the thing
we lived out of fruit jars
and uh
they were picking some tomatoes when
my brother bob
climbed up on the windmill
and maybe you could
bring that up yeah yeah that's one of
the one of the crazy accidents that you
saw when you were growing up
before we get to that
you had a section in here
and and the section this chapter of the
book is called moonshine
and you say paw made moonshine long
before i was born he was accommodating
people who needed to drink but had to
seek other means of getting it due to
prohibition i helped bottle the
moonshine when i was eight it was double
pure pretty close to two hundred percent
but he used distilled water to cut it
down to eighty-five percent alcohol
you tell a story in here about the first
time you got drunk which was around age
five
[Laughter]
coffee punch
yes and
it's funny we're chuckling about it now
but you saying here at one point
it happened one of dad's so-called
so-called friends turned him in and he
got six months in austin city jail for
selling moonshine
though the original sentence was up to
two years at leavenworth penitentiary
so your dad ended up going into jail for
a while
six months
celebrated their 25th wedding
anniversary
in the austin city jail
and i remember
on the way down there we we had a jewett
car
sedan
my brother leo was driving
i was eight years old at that time
and uh
brother leah was driving my mother did
not drive
but she was alongside and she had a
a cake anniversary cake to take along to
to my dad
and she said leo said look ma
we're going a mile a minute now
wow that that was moving 60 miles an
hour
man
what what an advance from the horse and
buggy
that's amazing
uh you you mentioned some of these
accidents you know you mentioned the
windmill one but
it's a whole sec
you've got a whole section in the book
of when you're growing up just called
accidents you had your sister get
get
injured by a manure spreader
you had a kid that got hit by lightning
yeah
you had one of your brothers
hit you in the face with a piece of you
know they're getting some kind of a
rocket fight yeah a lot of dirt
uh you guys were using dynamite when you
were kids to blow stumps out of the
ground yeah
um yeah you talked about in here
so your your brother bobby
uh
there's a windmill out by your house
about 60 feet tall
exactly 60 foot and there's a plank up
45 feet
and bobby was up there
climbed up there you're telling him to
get down before mom comes home
and you know he says oh don't worry
about it i'll be down by the time she
gets here
and he did
well one step again it's i guess it's
we're kind of chuckling about it now but
man in the book here let me let me read
a little section from the book
they heard him fall ran over and brought
him into the house carrying him into the
kitchen his eyeballs were out of their
sockets on his cheeks and blood shot out
of his ears whenever his heart beat he
was out cold
leo ran to uncle charlie's house because
he had a phone to call dr ertl who put
his eyeballs back into their sockets and
caught into his ears to slow the
bleeding
the doctor said his broken right arm
splitting it with cardboard
i didn't think it could get any worse
but the fall cracked his head too
the doctor instructed us get ice packs
on his head
elmer's steel had a nice house about a
mile from us so we got the ice from
there mom packed bobby's ice head and
ice held on with cloth diapers my mom
tied him to the bed so he wouldn't move
around feeding him soup and taking care
of him there's no nurse like a mother he
was her baby for what seemed like a
month he lapsed in and out of
consciousness until one day he sat up in
bed
asking where's jake i want to play with
jake and he was okay yeah
he lived till he was 75
he caught every disease that was known
to man
and
i
worked right by him
took took baths
in the same tub
wash tub
as he did
he had the measles i never got them i
never had a childhood disease
until i was 34 years old and i got the
lumps from my son bro bringing them home
from school
yeah you got some incredible detail
about that stuff in the book too
um
you ended up going to uh grammar school
you went to what is it lemon township
lehman
le mans township
you say you did homework by the kerosene
lamplight absolutely
yeah and that's you you're talking about
how that lamp light would get dirty you
have to clean it before you start your
homework oh yes
the wick would
would
cloud the
lamp
glass
that was clear glass
lamp
thing
that was
it was better than a candle
i guess the candles can only get so
bright kerosene lights can get pretty
bright
well
a lot brighter than
anything else but
it's uh that
we thought nothing of it
we thought it was a modern age at that
time and
we weren't the only ones everybody
that
around every farmer
and we were just for farmers
everybody lived the same way they had to
go through the same thing that
we weren't any different than anyone
else so
if you're not any different you don't
know the difference
now it sounds like for what was normal
for you for you guys back then was when
you got done with kind of grammar school
when you got done with eighth grade
sometimes you didn't you didn't continue
on with school you didn't go to high
school there was no
thing anybody going to high school it
was very unusual
that someone would go to high school and
and for you you had mrs jeffrey you sent
a note home that said i recommend that
you let jake go to high school because
he's a fast learner
that's it yeah oh do i remember that
like yesterday
and how did your dad react to that
my dad says there's no high school for
you you've got chores to do
you've got chores to do
and eventually it was your brother earl
that said he was 14 years older than me
was
and he was a horse man we had 30 horses
at that time
there was no thing as tractors or
anything everything was done by
horse-drawn
machinery
and earl was
took care of the horses and
shoot them and
the doctoring element broke them
from
wild horses to uh
working in the harness
and he ended up telling your dad that he
would help with the work so that you
would be able to go to school yeah he
would do my chores for me if if i got
got a chance to go to school
yes
and he did and then
i did i dedicated
part of this book to earl because i
would not be here today
if he hadn't done my chores
in the high school that you went to you
had to go
and live
somewhere else right yeah 14 miles away
and the roads are not open in the
wintertime there it was all done with
horses and sleighs so
you you can't go 14 miles every every
day morning and night in a slave so he
had to
had to stay in town with someone
and then you ended up in order to pay
for your room and board you ended up
pretty much working for one of your
friends moms who had a had a little
place to stay and you helped out there
one of my lucky breaks again
i
couldn't go out for any sports
i had to run home at noon
and put those
the meals on the table we had eight room
and borders that i
helped take care of
and uh
i i started high school when i was 12
years old
i graduated eighth grade at 12 and
being born in december i'm i'm still
12 when i started high school in
september
and
it's crazy people say whoa
but
when you tell people you're born in
1922. i didn't say
tell them that i only had 11 days in
1922.
you know i was born in december 20th
so so i was only 11 days of old in 1922
they called it a full year
mentally
uh so
i got to go to the book here
this this section here because it kind
of starts off your military career it
says in 1938 i was walking around town
on a saturday afternoon with my cousin
chick
outside roxy theater we saw a sign
saturday matinee gene autry america's
number one cowboy it cost 10 cents but
we didn't have a penny between us
chick suggested jake let's join the
national guard they pay twelve dollars
every three months
it sounded like a great way to ensure a
steady income but i pointed out chick
we're 15 you have to be 18. chick was a
lot taller and heavier set than me we
were like mutt and jeff he answered when
they ask how old we are just say 18. the
worst they can do is kick us out they
aren't going to arrest us
so we walked into the office at the
armory and i still remember the stocky
captain's name captain hugh h soper
he looked at he looked up from his desk
asking what can i do for you
sir we'd like to join the national guard
i was expecting him to ask how old we
were and i was ready to say 18. he
looked me in the eyes and asked what
year were you born
wow i had to think quick 1922 1923 1919
sir
chick had it easy since he was just
standing behind me he just followed suit
and answered the same thing
so soper stamped out our enlistment
papers and we were in
it was as easy as that no physical or
test required i joined company f 135th
infantry regiment of the 34th infantry
division the red bulls
so you're 15 years old 15 years old were
you did you look young
and no no
farmers looked rough okay so you looked
a little bit older
we looked older yeah
and
at that time
the national guard this is when hitler
was taken to sedaton land
and had just the next austria in 1938
so
our
our country was strictly against war
strictly against war they didn't they
didn't want anything to do
with
going to europe and messing up with what
hitler hitler was uh
was
pretty well known he he wasn't known at
that time
of all the killings and
labor
camps that he had
were forced labor
that all came out later and
when stuff like that comes out it's like
it is right now
it is hard to believe
that a person can be that way
so
the national guard was trying to fill
its units
that
to get up to full strength
so that in case of war
they had the strengths in africa
the army was only about a hundred and
fifty thousand strong at that time army
the whole army in the united states was
150 000
and
that's when
president roosevelt
put put
28 or 29 national guard units into
federal service
that that was
february 10 19
41.
i i had just turned 18
in
december 20th 1940
and
we're put in the federal service and
ship down camp claiborne louisiana
so
my god
had nearly a year and there went
went through the
louisiana maneuvers
belly up belly down and chigger-infested
land
poisonous snakes and
uh
what a place
it was a hell hole
you say in here i learned as much about
training for war combat as i did about
coping with chiggers ticks and intense
humidity oh god it was terrible it was
terrible and so that you left for that
february 1941
and so we still weren't out war yet
no but you but it the the country looked
like we were heading in that direction i
know you mentioned in here one of your
friends carlos
carlos bowkey yeah carlos bowkey he told
me jake let's join the air force i asked
him why and he said the money is better
and we'll get to be officers i thought
that sounded good at the time i was a
corporal getting 42 a month
while a private earned 30 a month carlos
and i decided to try and enlist so we
went through the physicals and written
tests the physicals involved in eye exam
carlos passed his but they told me i was
colorblind i had no idea then i found
out my brother todd was also colorblind
so you tried to join the air force but
you you couldn't see colors they
wouldn't let you in so you stayed in the
army so i stayed in the army
and i'm here today there's another thing
the luckiest man in the world
i turned out to be colorblind
but uh
the army didn't know that
i had never had a physical for
colorblindness
and the air core didn't tell them that i
was
colorblind but
it's an interesting interesting thing
there
if you want me to relate on
carlos bowkey
i will tell you
that
i am lucky probably that i didn't join
get into the aviation
carl smokey
died on his graduation day
in a flyby
two planes collided
and burned they don't even know which
body is that shipped back to barry
here i am
he was 19 years old at the time
here here i am
going on 99
with a family
a family
grandchildren
great-grandchildren
can you
question why i say i'm the luckiest man
in the world
no questions from my side of the table
sir
um
you so pearl pearl harbor happens
december 7th 1941.
um
i i kind of wanted to portray a little
bit of your uh let's say
let's say your rebellious spirit you had
a little rebellious spirit when you were
younger
um colonel schmidt the 135th infantry
commanding officer announced that all
the company clerks he had authority over
were authorized 15-day furloughs so you
were going to get 15 days of leave now
captain erickson eriksen
told you hey
get everyone set
only give people seven days
and you told him sir everyone will have
to turn around and come home before they
even get there
and he said corporal i'm your commanding
officer you will do as you are told
and so you do what you're told
except for on your papers you give
yourself 15 days leave so you can get
back home spend some time then come back
and he just went through the stack of
papers and signed them all
and you took your 15 days
that
that changed my life captain ericsson
was killed in the north africa invasion
the 34th division went down to north
africa
morocco or algeria there and
landed and he was killed down there and
the company clerk
is close to your captain so uh
and in the meantime i got transferred
into
fifth corps
right
he was trying to punish you by he was
trying to punish me moving you away from
him i was going to be
climbing poles and stringing wires
according to captain eriksen
um
but then you ended up
you ended up going into
the the g3 into operations
i i was the only operation sergeant
there
now is that because you knew how to type
that's because yeah
i was an expert typer where did you
learn how to type
i had one year of typing in high school
as an
elective yeah i was the only boy in a
class of 30.
it ended up being an extremely important
skill for your whole life it changed my
life
being able to type uh you say here being
part of the g3 so g3 for people that
don't know this is operations these are
people that are coming up with the plans
and and and directing how these
operations are going to go
and and you say here man being a part of
g3 was a whole different world instead
of reporting to a captain or lieutenant
i had to report to a full bird colonel
or a lieutenant colonel
you said once i was part of g3 i met i
met who would become one of my closest
friends while in the service corporal
madison rich he was from new jersey and
was a skilled typist just like myself
you said when i had free time i this is
by the way this is when you're i fast
forward past this part but this is when
you're overseas you're now in ireland
and england and you guys are preparing
for the invasion you say when i had free
time i'd hang out with my other pals
corporal cray and staff sergeant robbie
robert jeffrey cray was the cockiest
irishman i ever met while jeffrey was
subdued i was only 19 at the time and
they were both much older than me
because of my slight stature they
nicknamed me bony ass
well
i was five foot ten
weighed 120 pounds so
i uh
the luckiest man in the world
when i landed on d-day we were under a
lot of fire i had
two of those uh
mg-42
machine guns shooting at me and they
they only shoot 1200 rounds a minute
each one
so so you're
when you double it
it's quite a thing
but uh
the germans
were not used to shooting out toothpicks
so uh
i made it through
uh before you get to d-day you you have
one incident that i just i had to bring
up because um it end is another thing
that had a big impact on your life you
you were taking some pictures
and there was a major that you were with
ridgeway
and you say he had gotten out of his
jeep while he was talking to me so i sat
down in the jeep and handed him my 35
millimeter argus camera here major can
you take a picture of me sitting in your
jeep what's funny about the picture is
that it was the only jeep i ever sat in
while i was in the service i sent that
picture along with other pictures to my
mother my dad looked through them and
picked the picture of me sitting in the
jeep to bring to the photo
photo news they liked it well enough to
put in their paper adding a blurb about
corporal jake larson in north ireland i
was unaware of it at the time but that
picture
being published in the paper would lead
me to the love of my life and we'll
we'll get to that later
um
at this point
now you guys are and again i'm going to
fast forward a little bit but now you
leave to go to portsmouth to start the
planning for
portsmouth okay i'll say it that way so
you guys go to port's mouth to uh start
the planning
you're promoted to sergeant
and
and this is where you
you participate in that operation
or the training operation at slapton
sands which you talked about earlier
just a unbelievable travesty you go on
this training mission
these these these ships are filled with
soldiers to practice d-day
and the germans
actually sank some of those ships two of
those ships
795 people killed before d-day even
happened during a training operation
one month before d-day
and they the americans that died during
that they reported
they told the the families that they
died during d-day absolutely yeah
and that brings us to
d-day
and i just want to
read some of this and and just get your
feedback on it um
d-day was supposed to be june 5th so all
the troops were loaded into ships the
day before including me the sea was
getting rougher and rougher so they
called it off and we had to return
they had a british weather master who
told eisenhower there would be a break
in the weather in the morning so he
decided to have the invasion go on june
6th
by the time of the change i hadn't slept
for 72 hours just running on adrenaline
there are 7 000 ships on the move with
158 000 troops and our destination about
170 miles away everywhere you look there
was a ship and they were going to
different beaches everything was
programmed
i went in with the members of the first
infantry division on the uss ancon which
was the command ship about eight miles
from shore the landing craft pulled up
alongside us so we had to climb down
rope ladders into the boat carrying 75
pounds of gear
and our rifles
then we dropped into the landing craft
which was bobbing up and down in three
to four foot waves
you know we see images
uh produced by computers
to simulate what it looked like with all
those ships on d-day that must have been
an incredible sight
that's the most unbelievable thing
it's it's even hard to describe how do
you describe
that one
every every place you look
there's a ship and behind it another
ship and behind that more ships more
ships and more ships
how do you crowd seven thousand ships in
into a small area like that there
and
i'm on the ancon that's that's where
eisenhower was on
the commander that
little farm boy from hope minnesota
only graduated high school
and
i'm almost
a sergeant man
i worked on the invasion with colonel
hill
i got the bronze star for
for what i did
worked on i i didn't even know i was
going to get it
but uh
it's it's crazy
did you guys since you were part of the
planning
you must have had very good awareness of
what you were going into in terms of the
enemy positions oh yes it seems like you
would have known even more what you were
facing than the normal soldiers who
maybe weren't as involved in the
planning yeah
i was not a normal soldier at that time
i was the highest classified
person you can get
i was top secret
bigot be a g.o.t
most people don't even know what big it
is
but that's the highest
rating you can get
think of it a little farm boy from hope
minnesota
when i told people that uh afterwards
that uh i was classified top secret
bigot yeah what what's that
you know
it didn't mean anything to them
and this was your first
combat operation was d-day yeah yeah
yeah absolutely it was the first
for all of our troops
what was the what was the fear level
there was no fear level we wanted that
we had been over to england
then
for
two and a half years
we'd been over there
planning this thing
and
we wanted to get it done
get it done
they kept putting it off and putting it
off and finally when
you got to go
the weather wasn't very good but but
in the long run the weather kind of
helped us
it took the germans off guard
even rommel who was
guarding that part went home to
celebrate his wife's birthday
you say here i was the last off last one
off the ship when they dumped us out too
far we marched off the ramp into the
water and all walked in a line i made my
way into the icy water that reached up
to my chin holding my rifle over my head
but i wasn't thinking about the water's
temperature i just wanted to get through
it alive the section of shore i landed
on was known as easy red we were
supposed to be able to walk through the
surf and find bomb holes which would be
shelters for us the air corps totally
missed omaha beach so there was no
protection for us
those beaches were all mined
i would find out later in life that
there were millions of mines on that
beach if you stepped on one of those
babies it was a quick trip to heaven i
was more afraid of stepping on a mine
than being shot at i ran toward the
cliffs making sure to step in the same
footprints as the man in front of me
made
what in the hell am i doing here
the thought pounded in my head as i
dodged bullets determined to stay
focused on reaching the safety of the
cliffs
how did a simple farm boy from minnesota
land on omaha beach on d-day
machine guns were firing in all
directions with bodies everywhere
those mg-42 machine guns shot 1200 to
1500 rounds per minute
i ran and dodged finally making my way
to a sand berm
the bullets were blasting off the berm
as i ducked into it i wasn't going to
get out of that hole no matter what
i smoked at that time and i had my
cigarettes in this plastic bag so they
wouldn't get wet unfortunately i didn't
have a match
i remember then that i started shaking
before that moment i had felt no fear
i turned to my left and left and saw a
soldier lying down with his back toward
me i called out hey buddy do you have a
match
then i noticed there was no head
underneath the helmet
that got me moving jake move i told
myself
i got up and dashed for the bottom of
the cliff wall about 200 yards away i
remember saying to myself jake what the
hell are you doing here you're running
for your life so nobody can shoot at you
but everybody can shoot at you
i only weighed 120 pounds soaking wet so
that was an advantage since it's hard to
shoot at a toothpick
after what seemed like an eternity
i made it to the cliff wall where i was
safe
from what i've read over 2500 died at
omaha beach that day
that was on easy red to work where i
went in on that's where
i look back
i went back to uh
omaha beach on the 75th anniversary
of d-day
and
i had
five
different
tv stations
bbc
france one france two
cbs
nbc
waiting at the cemetery
of an omaha beach cemetery i have never
been in a
military cemetery at the time
and they said we want you to walk out
there
and
look at one of the tombstones
stand there
while we take pictures
i walked out there i came i told you i
came in with the
with
part of the first division the 16th
infantry regiment
the first tombstone i i landed
looked at
said that
here this this
private
from the 16th infantry regiment was
buried there
i'm standing there with my hat on
and coat
i didn't know that
you don't salute
thing
so i raised my right hand with my hat
above my head
that that picture
went viral
all over the world
it's like
the the
ghosts
of those guys buried there that day
were down there watching me
and when i raised
my hat ins a salute to them
it was like a response that i got from
the guys
after all i'm not the hero those guys
that are buried they're the heroes
i made it true because they put their
life up for me
i keep telling people
i am not the hero
i'm a here too i told you that i i
changed from hero to here too they said
what is it here too i'll say here to
tell you the story of my life
and it's unbelievable but
i'm here because of that
and that's what's got me through life
so when you got to the cliff
and now
you're you're so you're i guess you're a
little bit out of the enemy fires
there's still enemies
they can't fire it about underneath
themselves got it but you still have to
push through barbed wire and guys start
getting out the bangalore torpedoes
right yeah and
that was a dangerous one because the guy
that shoved those bangalore torpedoes up
two of them were killed right there
but but as quick as they went off and we
started going up above and got behind
the germans they they have no protection
they cleared out fast
so it didn't take long
and then we
got to set up
i have
periods of
total blankness and this is one of them
the next thing i knew
we had set up the command post i don't
even remember setting it up
and
i was digging a foxhole with corporal
rich
and that's a kind of an interesting
thing too
if you yeah
yeah so um
you're setting up this command post you
don't remember a lot of it
and and you say um i was relieved to see
my good friend corporal madison rich who
arrived in a different landing craft
than i
that right there must have been amazing
to
see all these guys get killed
and you happen to one of your other
friends from a different landing craft
happens to make it yeah he stayed in the
foxhole next to mine
and i had my litter down in my foxhole a
litter was just a canvas cloth fast
between two removable sticks on either
side i slept on top of it to keep
moisture and dampness off my body we
didn't have sleeping bags we made our
own with wool blankets provided calling
them fart sacks which by the way we
still called sleeping bags fart sacks in
the military when i was in
uh once i found out
i had to work that night i told corporal
rich you can sleep in my foxhole tonight
i've got the litter in there thanks jake
i got my fart sack all made up now i'm
not changing it
nevertheless he laid his m1 rifle on my
litter
and went to sleep
that night the germans wanted to see
what we were up to so they sent over
reconnaissance planes dropping flares to
take pictures after midnight they lit up
the beach like daylight our
anti-aircraft started shooting it up at
those planes well what goes up must come
down so when matty rich got up in the
morning he went to pick up his rifle in
my foxhole
only for it to fall in two pieces the
shrapnel from our men shooting at the
germans had hit his rifle during the
night
talk about luck
they had called on me to work that night
and he's fortunate he didn't take me up
on my offer of sleeping there
so there you go
it seems like it's a story of my life
to be in the right place at the right
time
yeah so we're in your bed where you were
going to sleep that night the rifle that
was sitting on your bed
in half
fell in two yeah
and
if you ever saw some
m1 grand that's a pretty hefty
pretty hefty rifle it's uh weighs eight
pounds
so
it had to take some kind of a direct hit
to to be able to fall
into and during this time you're
supposed to be
working during the day and then getting
some sleep at night but what's happening
for these first five six seven days
you're working during the day and then
at night you all have to move yeah so
you're not getting any sleep at all
i
the action all took place during the day
very little action during the night
so
when i'd try to sleep
during the day
the germans would
show us
that was right at the same st low then
was
the place we were trying to capture and
they told us it was going to
take a few days to capture took us a
month
took us a month
germans don't like like to give up
and
they are great fighters man we had our
hands full
but uh
we we um
covered a book on this podcast
called the clay pigeons of st low by
glover johns who was one of the officers
that that fought there
and
so you were there for that you say about
a month after d-day we were supposed to
capture a little town called saint lo we
moved from the cliffs to the hedgerows
of the town we planned to capture it
without delay but it took us about a
month because the germans put up such
stiff resistance
we put out orders and then different
units under our command carried them out
at that time other infantry units had
landed on d-day with us and those troops
were under our control
we would storm them or open fire
civilians didn't count they didn't
factor into the equation you have to
take that position in war if they're in
the way or on the road you just rush
them off
that's why so many civilians were killed
during the war
we tore the hell out of st low
i spent most of my time during the
daylight thinking of getting some sleep
but again we were always on the move we
were captured after we captured st low i
went to bed in the morning and woke up
at 2 am unable to remember how i got
there
i had been numb thinking only of sleep
sleep sleep
each soldier each soldier carries a tent
shell half tent shell
so i put my shelter half in a ditch and
there was three feet high next to the
road if you don't have another soldier
with you you have to make do with you
half a tent
i was thinking about brushing my teeth
and shaving i noticed another soldier
walking around carrying something i took
the liner out of my helmet and poured
some water into it so i could brush my
teeth
and was just about to shave when one of
the soldiers asked hey what the hell are
you doing here i explained i'm going to
shave i work at night i just woke up he
said this is supposed to be all clear
there's 155 meter
uh millimeter shell
laying on the road and we're sandbagging
it to detonate it
so there you are going to brush your
teeth and there's a
unexploded shell you happen to run into
these guys
not anything close
not any farther away than you and i
sitting right now
i don't think if that thing went off i
don't think even the luck would get you
through that one no no
not the only one
my luck hell though you're lucky helped
uh
here's another one and another
another piece of evidence for the
luckiest man in the world colonel hill
asked me what i was doing i said i was
thinking about getting something to eat
he said i got a jeep coming up from the
motor pool and i'll i'll tit i'd like to
you to ride along with it to look at our
next command post check it out
for colonel hill i would do anything the
guy saved my saved my life a few times
by putting me in charge of the night
shift i responded gladly sir
we had a hand-drawn map of the area
a private drove the jeep as i looked at
the map suddenly i realized we missed
the turn off
so i said to the private i think we
missed the turn off it was there was a
ditch there
the culvert indicated the rhodes
entrance
so just as he got the jeep turned around
another jeep turned down that road
hit a land mine and blew up
that was the place we were supposed to
turn
somebody was looking out for me i swear
i went we went back to colonel hill
reporting the incident he uttered you're
like a cat with nine lives
yeah
you're using up some of those nine lives
in these events
didn't get a scratch
didn't get a shot
look that came to
the whole battle of the bulge and i was
one of
one of the first ones
after the battle of the bulge think of
it i'm one of the first ones to get
leave
to come home before the war is over 45
days
unbelievable lucky
but i had a
it was on the point system right
and
i had 127 points and you were at the top
of the list that was off the top of the
list because the points were based on
how long you've been in the service and
how long overseas and
yeah
yeah and before you even get to the
battle of the bold shortly after that we
moved through a narrow valley called the
phalae's gap valet valet's gap where we
had a german army partially trapped
the english came in from the west while
we came in from the southeast
part of patton's troops was there plus
the five core we captured fifty thousand
german soldiers and killed nearly that
many
we bombarded them from three sides when
we got there the shooting was over
that's the first time i ever walked over
dead people and around dead horses when
we landed on omaha beach i had never
stepped over any of our soldier
soldiers that's like stepping on your
brother
i didn't get the same feeling walking
over the enemy
what was the what was the um
what was the feeling about patton did
you guys all know who was he as
legendary back then for you guys
well uh
patton
first army
was the one that
landed on d-day first army
and
fifth core and seventh core
were the two cores under first army
now fifth core
had
omaha beach all of omaha beach
i was the only operations sergeant in
in
fifth corps
g3
so
think about this this little farm boy
from hope minnesota
minuscule place 100
occupants there
farmers
was in charge of that every night think
of that
how is that possible
because earl
volunteered to do my chores for me and i
got
like i took typing one one year
it's crazy when you look back at it it's
it's plain crazy
it's hard for
me to understand how it is
it's hard for me to be here i'm going to
be turning 99.
i i cannot believe that i am here
i'm i'm the only one left of all the
people i was in the service with
there's nobody else that i was in with
alive
and
sitting here
going to be 99
without an acre or pain in my body how
is that possible
there's got to be an answer somehow
and
i say there is a god
that's my favorite saying
there is a god
and he certainly looks out for you
that's for sure he's been taking care of
me great
uh
the next thing that you did
was
to capture paris the liberation of paris
what was that like
that
there was another thing
the free french
when we came in the germans had gave
gave up
the general said called
off
he wasn't fight back
but the free french came in there and
while the germans were evacuating
they came in there and threw those
uh
molotov cocktails
into their trucks and everything
but
if you'd have been treated like the
french were treated
for four years
i have a different view see where i'm
coming in
i wasn't
subjected to any of the germans or
anything we were there just just to
fight them so
it was kind of hard for me to realize
that
these people suffered
suffered
there were thousands and thousands of
them who were
drafted and and put into
the army with the
with the germans
being an american and
with the liberties that we have
it's hard to transform
your opinions
when you're being killed and shot at and
abused
i i just don't know how to put it
and and you as a farm boy from
hope
minnesota ended up having a pretty nice
office once you got it
marshall paton's office
how how did things like this happen
it's crazy
so so marshall paton was the was the guy
in charge of
the the
the viki french
yeah the bishop the vici french
he was
he he was
the one that led the french through the
first world war right
and
i sat at his desk and it was loaded with
medals of all kinds
that
now
the french gave me the legion of honor
uh
or 2014
they announced that
i would have the legion of honor
and in 2015 february
we went to uh san francisco to the
france french
where
their officials were
and
there was ten of us
that that sat there and we were each
percent what the legion of honor that
besides the legion of honor
i was the only one
to
receive
the french
retired
soldier
badge
i'm an honorary
french retired soldier
not that little red white and blue one
right there
it's it's one of the
i'm proud of that
beyond being proud i'm
mostly proud to be american
but
the french recognize
that that i had
been working for them and
gave me that along with the legion of
honor
i i don't know of any other soldier
in the american army
that has to receive that honorary
retired
french soldier
that's that's definitely an honor um
and even as you know you say the
the germans kind of gave up paris but it
wasn't over yet yeah and and you had
even more close calls you you say this
here as after we moved out moved out of
paris we ended up in luxembourg
since i work nights after i get some
rest during the day i'd have some free
time to walk on the cobblestone streets
we were in a valley and i came to an
intersection at the foot of a hill i had
just started crossing the road when an
english spitfire and a german
messerschmitt right on its tail
shot over the hill the messerschmitt
firing its cannon at the spitfire when
they came down the hill
the cannon shot right in front of me
shattering the cobblestones into pieces
i landed on my face in the cobblestones
and got the hell out of there once again
it was unbelievable how lucky i was
i say this close only counts in
horseshoe and grenades
[Laughter]
oh
uh you mentioned the battle the bulge
earlier on this on december 16th at two
in the morning i was on duty when a
corporal drove up to the command post
came in and reported he was so excited
that he saluted me a staff sergeant
he declared i'm at guard post number six
and of course we got out the operations
map so i could see right where he was
just south of manshaw manshu i'm not
sure
he told me that the german paratroopers
were coming down
i asked when when you saw them coming
down what did you do i got in the jeep
and came right here
so that was the beginning of the battle
of the dead
and
the uh the germans put had had pows
american pows took their uniforms
and then went out
into this area and started changing the
road signs and
doing they were spying and stuff and you
talked about the fact that
if you caught those people when those
people were caught
they were shot
no trial was necessary for those men
killed on the spot
and then the german tanks started to
roll through
melbody melanie
they
lined up
all these
guys that were
uh
artillery observers
they caught i think 180
80 of our our guys were were caught
there and lined up in the ditch with
their hands over their head
and it was snowing at the time when
the german tanks rolled by
and
colonel pfeiffer
of the who led the germans at that time
ordered those tanks
to fire their machine guns at these guys
in the ditch
that that's called the malmedy massacre
now did you hear how long did it take
for you to hear about that oh i got it
but about an hour
about an hour that word got back fast
we were we were cut off
from the first army
when they went through there
and
we we ended up
being part of
general montgomery's
21st army group
and uh the to talk about luck
patton was
they ordered
to get help from patton from the third
army that was a long ways away
but by the time
patton got there
montgomery we were part of montgomery's
21st army group think that that
we're the fifth corps was the only one
that was part of
patton's for
patton's 21st army and
we had the first and
29th i think or 29th or 28th division
either one one of those others at the
time uh
that slipped my my mind that
that
my mind is
pretty full of stuff
but uh
i can't tell you for sure which one but
anyway
we we put the squeeze on the germans
from two sides
they had nowhere to go
except drop their weapons and march out
and they ran out of fuel
they left all their vehicles right there
they
they walked out
i was reading some history about this
and i guess
six different occasions this was this
was hitler's plan was to push into you
know to push push
to push through there and six times his
generals objected to the plan and said
this isn't a good idea we shouldn't do
this and six times he said no we're
doing it anyways
not listening he was not listening to
his his his subordinates
did he ever no
he just fired him
so as they pushed back and that that
battle the battle of the bulge lasted
almost a month and a half something like
that
well
i got out of there december 31st okay
that's where when i got 45 days leave it
i'll tell you this story of that
december 31st
the colonel hill called me in and said
i got a
referral for you
you're you're going to go home for 45
days
and
oh my god i couldn't believe it
i had
rifles and stuff
under colonel hill's
bed
he had this truck that uh
his
bed and everything was in that
and
it was a good place to store stuff so he
didn't mind
sleeping over
but i i left that stuff over there
when
i was going just unfertile see
i thought i'd be back
to
pick that up
so
it took me
51 days
to get home
and uh and part of that was transporting
wounded right oh we ended up on a ship
from the harbor
yeah from from la harv
to portsmouth
i think two or three ship loads of
wounded
so you as you tried to leave
there's like we mentioned like i
mentioned earlier there's 47 000 wounded
during the battle the bulge so instead
of
the ships being able to take people home
on furlough you ended up on these ships
getting people transported where back to
england
yeah
to portsmouth england
portsmouth england
is where we'd stop and unload those
ships again
and then go back and get another load
see
and here i'm supposed to be headed
across the atlantic
and
but
think of this
when i do get home
when i do get home and spend my 45 days
at home
i go up to fort snelling
and a captain called calls me in
he says sergeant
ten minutes ten minutes ago i got a call
from the pentagon
and they told me that
i
they
they let me
i could stay home or go back to germany
my god after three years over there
there's no way i'm going back to germany
so all all the relics that i had under
colonel hill's
bad
they were given up
don't know what happened and i don't
miss some one of them
[Laughter]
so that that's uh
as you as you get home
i can't even imagine
going from that many months of direct
combat
and just
getting on a ship getting back to
america what was it like when you got
home especially before you found out
that you were going to get to stay home
oh wait
my mother was dying from a heart disease
called
leakage of the heart it was a valve in
there
and
i i never thought i'd see her
anymore
but she was still living
and she lived for
five years after that
she
saw her grandchildren two of her
grandchildren at that time
and
i say there is a god
but
two weeks after my mother passed away
dr dr hoffnagel
in washington dc
invented that valve
that would have cured her
but
you can't turn back time
if
it's like crying over spilt milk say
you can't pick it up
it's done
um
so
was there anything else about the war
when when you were there like on a
day-to-day basis
how did you how did you handle that how
did you face
you know you said when you were going to
d-day you weren't really afraid
then once you were getting shot at
behind this bike
i asked what the hell am i doing here
if you're in that position you want to
be able to fight back
well there's no way you can fight back
there
they're protected from fire and
you have to know exactly where they are
what little hole they're shooting out of
and it's pretty hard to determine when
you're running for your life
and
dodging
it's a
circumstance you don't ever want to be
in
but
you're not the only one
mind you you you got all the guys around
you that are doing the same thing and
some of them being shot and
that'll spur you on a little bit too
when somebody gets shot
puts a little bit umpus in you but
yeah
so when you get back
and now you find out that
that you they're gonna discharge you
you're done with the army you're done
with the army uh you say that here you
say i was done that was april 13th 1945
and the war ended in may i was just 22
years old with seven years of soldiering
under my belt
it's crazy when you think about that
so
that's it the war is over for you
and now it's uh
you start off by going back to farm life
right yeah i've started helping my dad
by rebuilding the the hog shed
cementing and everything
and then
i started to think
i'm gonna have to have some kind of
occupation they don't like
they don't care about uh
hiring somebody for just shooting people
you know and
so
i
enrolled in dunwoody institute
i took
training in electricity
the
radio tv
anything to have to do with
electricity
what
i did
and
in fact after i got out of there i
i had my own
service station for a while
and
man
having a service station
making a center gown
and when when they rebuild the highway
alongside of you
and no one can get in there except for
the back streets
and they said they were going to dump 30
000 gallons on me
a month
i told him where to shove that
service station
and
i went and got a job in austin minnesota
as a lineman
climbing poles to string in wire
i did that for four years
i'm a journeyman lineman i got a
journeyman license
um
and uh so captain erickson finally got
his wish of you being up in the uh
drinking wires
that's a hard job
uh and meanwhile
you also met lola oh god yes i fell in
love
you said uh
you were you were going out in september
1945 soon thereafter we were going out
every night in october i got an
engagement ring and asked her to marry
me it seemed rapid to me but i was
infatuated october went by then november
came along and i told lola that it was
killing me and that we had to doing
something about it we arranged to have a
wedding at the lutheran church in austin
where my sister peg and my
brother-in-law lived
november 23rd simple wedding
she moved in
and and she and i slept in a closet on a
bed no wider than a couch
worked out great for a while
[Music]
and plus we're lucky you don't take up
much room
[Laughter]
uh
you say this when i got when i came home
from the service i had the shakes
but nobody visited doctors for
post-traumatic stress disorder back then
i woke up one night and i was choking
lola so we got separate beds she
realized what i had gone through she was
there for me 100
i had to learn how to drink coffee with
my left hand because my right hand shook
so much
i started taking
what is that pro
propranolol
protaninol for that
and still take it to this day
so there's there's definitely even
though you came home from the war the
war was kind of still going on in some
ways
none of the world war ii
veterans
had medical help like that in fact when
when
when i went to get
medical help
i had
i got 11 cents in me eleven in your
heart
well or around your mouth around your
heart okay
i was feeling faint
and
went down to the hospital and
they were checking me out and they
couldn't figure out what was wrong with
me and they wanted to keep me overnight
there is a god
so
they kept me
in the hospital and hooked me up
to every
kind of a
thing of wires all over me
the next morning
i woke up in a neighboring hospital
instead of walnut creek
kaiser
i woke up in mount diablo
in concord
25 miles away
at 2 o'clock in the morning
that alarm went off
i had
cardiac arrest
that means i was dead for a while
but you were hooked up to a machine
machine and they got to work on you
immediately yeah
and got me got me
oh boy
crazy
you you tell the story in here i
mentioned that that the picture earlier
that the major took of you while you
were sitting in the jeep
and that picture got published in the
newspaper
and then uh you say this one day i came
home from work finding lola changing her
wallet
she had all the remains of her old
wallet dispersed across the table i
walked by thinking enough of nothing of
it until something caught my eye i
noticed a picture of a young soldier
sitting inside an army jeep but that
wasn't just any soldier that was me
she had the picture of me and her wallet
from years ago when i was in major
ridgeway's jeep
the one that was in the local paper
i asked her where did you get that
picture and she told me that she cut it
out of the paper and put it in her
wallet
i said you didn't even know me
she said no but i met your brother bob
and he was talking about you at the time
she was a sophomore going to high school
her family had just moved two farms
north of us near hope i never met her or
her family and didn't even know she
existed while she was in high school one
of her girlfriends questioned her for
keeping the photo and asked who's the
guy in this picture she announced that
is the guy i am going to marry
how can you make up something like that
my life is
unbelievable up until then
and it keeps on going being unbelievable
so you have your first son kurt
in 1948
uh
you you end up with that lineman job
you have your second child linda
and then you go
you go you become a tv radio repairman
after you do the service station you end
up moving to california when you get to
california you're doing you're working
for sears as a tv repairman for 2.35
cents an hour
your brother-in-law has a print shop up
in northern california
he offers you a hefty raise up to 3.42
cents an hour
and you so you go up there and do that
you you end up
also doing tv repair on the side
working with you know replacing people's
tubes and whatnot
so now it's
years go by
and and you say this while working for
my brother-in-law i'd come home about 3
30 or 4 every day and then worked fixing
televisions one particular day i'll
never forget i came home from the print
shop and lola met me at the door i said
hi hun
don't don't haunt me you son of a gun
of a [__]
wow that shook me up what's the problem
honey the problem is i'm pregnant you
son of a [__]
yeah pregnant you would better get the
doctor to make sure well the reason she
was because this is what 10 years after
your last kid yeah
10 years exactly 10 years
um so that's you end up having another
another baby yeah uh
you go to and there is a god
you work at jonas printing you work at
harrington mcginnis printing
for a while
um
you end up getting a house
uh
here's a conversation in 1990 we were
still living in pleasant hill california
as usual it went
to uh i i still went to the flea market
every sunday in january carlin found me
and said mom wants to talk to you lola
was sitting in the car with the first
word out of her mouth i knew i didn't
have a chance i knew i was screwed she
looked at me and said father i found my
dream house he had a father that melted
me
so uh
what do you mean by dream house a house
we can live in with my two sons and
their families i want you to come look
at it
all i could think was man this is gonna
cost me a lot
uh
so you say the place was going to take a
lot of work so it seemed ridiculous
to me to buy a new home when i was in my
late 60s because i didn't know how long
i'd be living
but you end up buying the house lola
moved into the house in martinez
during the construction renovations
followed by carlin and kim then kurt
linda wasn't interested in moving in
because she already had a home with her
husband and family i lived in pleasant
hill while our house was up for sale the
housing market was slow at the time
because the interest rate was at 12
while i stayed at pleasant hill the
house and martinez really came together
all of lola's ideas coming to life i was
starting to see what she saw in that
house
so you end up with a compound for the
family yes
and it
kept me alive
i had another incident where i
couldn't get out of
bed in the morning the alarm went off
a radio alarm
just a radio came on loud
and
i'm laying there thinking
like
right here right now
as sharp as my my mind was as sharp as
it is right now
but i couldn't
move a muscle
i had a
telephone right alongside of me
to to call my kids
i couldn't move and i said what the hell
am i going to do now
your bladder starts talking to you get
me to the bathroom
or you're going to be sorry
and
the next thing i knew
my oldest son came down from upstairs
and he says
the radio was going
he says daddy
have you got a problem
kurt
i can't move
i got to get to the bathroom
he says i'll go get carlin
so so when they started moving me
i passed out
the next thing i knew i was woke up in
kaiser walnut creek
i had a
stroke
and
they said
if i'd have been any later it would have
affected me i'm
right now i have a little
kind of a
my my left side
i got
my my left hand
it's it's wrinkled in there
and
my left foot i kind of dragged my left
foot
but
there is a god i'll tell you that
does it let me
my mind complete
um
so while you
were living in pleasant hill
you got a call one day lola called me
and said father i want you to come down
there and stay with you i want to come
down there and stay with you go to work
and get a rollaway bed god i
i hate to even talk about that day
she said i'm losing too much weight
because i miss your kids cooking
i asked how much weight she lost i lost
40 pounds last month
40 pounds
you say they found out she had stomach
cancer
don't worry dad linda said they're gonna
operate they think they can get it all
they might have to take some of her
stomach out but she can live a normal
life
she would have to eat less but more
often i just wanted anything and
everything done for her to keep going
the doctors opened her up discovering
that it did spread to her intestines
they gave her six weeks to live but she
lived a little longer than expected
curt and carlin fixed up the room in the
house that looked towards mount diablo
so she could look out the window and
enjoy the view one of the last things
she saw was that view
it's a beautiful sight
a day doesn't go by when i don't think
of her knowing that she's guiding me
she wrote a poem about me
i never was much on poetry but lola
loved to write
she titled the poem one of the lucky
my husband was one of many a second
world war volunteer
who left home to go serve his country
this land that we all love so dear
he never complained
he was lonesome
surrounded by enemy guns
the letters he wrote home were cheerful
like the battle was only fun
in his foxhole there death sat beside
him with shells whistling over his head
he tried to remember his childhood
tucked safely away in his bed
his buddies they fell by the dozen
on the beach their lives ebbing away
in my heart i think god had watched over
him
when he made it to cover that day
time and again
he was lucky
he still ran
when his best buddies fell
a dodging and jumping and
dying in this man-made inferno to hell
but the day came when his nerves had
shattered
and the general so plainly could see
this boy should no longer see battle
so they sent him home safely
to me
beautiful poem
checks me up
sets me up
well you you uh you were very lucky
not just to avoid
machine guns and
bombs and
everything else you were also very lucky
that you met your beautiful wife
and you were able to spend so much time
with her
i tell you
somebody up there likes me
i can't figure it out
somebody must like me
or like whatever way i do things
um
even after lola died you kept working
and then finally in 1995 when you were
73 your boy said dad we don't want you
to work anymore
you retired
after working for 19 years at harrington
mcginnis
but then you still kept a schedule
so how old were you when you were
retired oh 73
but you
you'd
run errands and and cook for the family
taking the kids all over the place to
different schools and
stuff had to you had to stay focused
had a new mission
i had a new responsibility in life
i had a
granddaughter
who who was three when i was 73
and i became the sole razor of her
she she's a dancer on a cruise ship now
dancer singer
and she is the one responsible
for putting me on tick-tock
i would not be here right now
she she's
mostly responsible for this book
it's unbelievable
it is unbelievable luckily you're
sitting here to
see that it is believable yes
it's crazy crazy
uh
you know you
a little earlier in the book you were
talking about
having the shakes in your hand
and you say i came out of world war ii
with the shakes in my right arm
i couldn't pick up a cup of coffee
without shaking without my hand shaking
so i learned a drink with my left hand i
took medication for it but it didn't
alleviate it
completely and then
one time you fell down
and when you fell down you went to the
hospital you were knocked out you went
to the hospital you got 30 stitches
uh
30 stitches in your head and the side of
my head and 29 stitches in your right
hand
uh you went to got a bunch of mris and
whatnot
um
before you went in the mri machine i got
to read this part he said i got down to
the mri room and the guy who was
operating the mri machine said i have to
ask you a few questions before i put you
in the machine i replied go right ahead
he asked me a series of questions like
what year is it
etc then he asked are you pregnant
i answered i've been screwed so many
times i ought to be
[Laughter]
well the mri came back without any
problems but but you the shake went away
after after 70 years no no no we're
sitting here
i want you to look at this
i could be an eye doctor
absolutely
think about i couldn't hold a cup of
coffee in that hand
before i fell on my
left side
and left side right hand
it correlates that's a miracle
i am a miracle itself it's crazy and so
then you end up getting cataract surgery
you've been colorblind your whole life
and what happens after cataract surgery
i get my color vision back
on easter sunday it's easter sunday
crazy so you can see color now i i see
color now you were color blind your
whole life
you're saying
you see all these colors
i can't tell you what color that is but
it's kind of an orangey red
yes it is
but
and that's a blue in this
i i i see all these colors
i don't know the names of them
because i was brought up without color
unbelievable
it's crazy
and the you know you mentioned earlier
going over
going being having the opportunity to go
to the 75th anniversary of d-day part of
that was because of a
of a
donations on a gofundme
to get you sent over there
well
that that's a very interesting thing
because all my service records were
burned up in
kentucky
in 1973
the elves and the m's were burned up
so uh
i i don't know if i put this in
about
one middle of what i i did get the
bronze star
earl heaps
was a newcomer to the bagel shop group
and
he he was a sergeant in
korea and uh
he says do you ever get any medals
jake yeah i said i got the bronze star
he says
bring bring it in
i've never seen the bronze star
we had just moved from
pleasant hill into
our home
in martinez
so
i
looked for that bronze star i could not
find it i looked every place
where would i my god what happened to
that thing but
then my daughter said that
linda says that
dad don't worry about i'll just
write to the army and have it replaced
i said you can do that oh yeah
they'll replace it for you
so
so i went up and told
earl heaps that
i couldn't find it
that they were going to replace it
a month later
linda came to me and says dad
they they don't know what
anything about your bronze star
they
all your records were burned
in kentucky
and they don't even know if you served
in the service
man that's a shaker upper
and
so so i tried to
find out and man
i i am a gi
three years overseas
i don't even have
v.a
help for a
doctor or anything
and it's probably a damn good thing
because i'm still alive
[Laughter]
i don't think they would give 11 cents
to me
in the v.a
um
you uh
but they ended up raising money for you
and you found your bronze star i found
out
you found your bronze star yeah
i gotta tell you about this
when i went back and told
earl heaps
that uh
my bronzer was lost
and they they they told me
we we don't even know if you served in
the service and earl heap says
well then we don't have to believe a
damn thing you've told me
you've been telling us
man that's a stabber
but you did find the brush oh we found a
brush an old ammo can or something
in an ammunition
box
and
here's the irony thing
it was some 40 caliber ammunition
and
i asked
who who wanted that ammunition i didn't
want that around i had some handguns
that fit and i've got too many gran
grandchildren
it's so uh
earl heap says
i'll i'll take it i've got some here
earl heaps
the one who told me we don't have to
believe a damn thing you told us
i opened that ammunition box and there
that
bronze star was laying in the box right
on top
i don't remember putting it on in there
and
no one else did too but
when i could produce the bronze star
earl had to eat his words he had to eat
his words
did i say that
yeah
yeah he did
um
so you raise the money you end up
going to normandy and you talked about
this but i i just want to read this
section because it's so moving you you
say we drove straight from paris to
normandy to the american cemetery the
first grave i saw was a private from the
first infantry division that choked me
up because i went on in on d-day with
members of the first infantry division
and now i was looking down at his grave
75 years later
it's kind of a weird feeling
i made it
and he didn't
look at the family i have while he has
nothing
war is so unfair i took off my hat
thanking him for paving the way for me
i teared up and walked away
i never realized the cemetery had over 9
000 americans
i was never one for visiting cemeteries
there are souls still hanging around but
this visit was different
i owed it to those who had been killed
to pay my respects
and as you mentioned earlier you ended
up doing a bunch of interviews for
french tv and cbs and
hey
i want to add two one
that you'll never hear
anybody else say
from russia
from moscow
a young girl
came up to me after
the the five
other ones came
were done she came up and said i'm from
moscow russia
and i'd like to interview you the
perfect english
i've never heard that
anyone being interviewed from anybody
from russia
it's crazy
um
that you also went back to omaha beach
itself
and you say here i returned to a section
of omaha beach where i walked on the
sand for the first time in 75 years with
my family and news groups
i tell you
it's hard for me to talk about it
you you can't you can't imagine
what we're going to
the memories that come back to you
and here i'm standing there with my son
my two sons
it's uh
because you ended up seeing a berm that
was basically exactly what you had
behind it it's like
like it was recreated for me
how is that possible
um
they had a big ceremony
uh
you shook the president's hand at the
ceremony
yeah president trump's hand
did a bunch more interviews
and uh
you say this the d-day anniversary trip
was the trip of a lifetime that i will
never forget what a moving memory
surpassing d-day in my mind
there was no killing
and we were celebrating it was the
epitome of my life
i'm so grateful for all the people who
came together in order for me to make it
back there i never in my life thought i
would return to that beach but i'm glad
that i did
i did not return for myself
but instead from my fellow soldiers who
did not make it
in all those interviews that you did you
know the word spread you ended up
hearing from uh
corporal madison rich you ended up
hearing his kids
about the gun incident
breaking into
man
he told his children about that
i i didn't
i never had
much contact
we were working when we
got out of service we didn't have time
for
messing around
talking about what we did in in a
service
but
after he passed away
his wife contacted me
and
i kept in contact with her for the years
and then she passed away
and
man
all of a sudden i'm over in europe i'm
in europe celebrating
the 75th anniversary of d-day
and
in new york
a man there
is listening and
jake larson they're talking about jake
larson
so he calls his brother in in new jersey
he says frank
are you watching that thing
about d-day the 75th anniversary
yeah he says i am
i wonder if that
jake larson they're talking about it's
the same one dad used to talk about
when the rifle broke into and he was
laid his rifle under
so they got a hold of my
youngest son carlin he's kind of
takes care of all my
appointments and things
and
they they called him
and he
told some hey i wonder if that jake
larson is the same guy that my dad was
talking about
then carl says well what's your dad's
name
he says madison rich
clown said that's the same one
i
personally
got got in contact
those two
two girls and two boys
madison rich
contacted me
we talked on the phone
face to face
and the oldest boy came down and saw me
personally
what a wonderful thing
madison rich did not make
70 years old
my god i worked until i was 73
and here i set going on 99.
there's something wrong in the equation
how one person could
could do these things
i
i need help
why am i still here
how come i don't have extra pains like
anybody else
life is crazy
there is a god
yeah and there is somebody that somebody
i guess if you look at the world there's
got to be somebody that actually is the
luckiest man in the world then that's
the name of the book and i think we're
finding out it's non-fiction
it certainly isn't
non-non-fiction at
and
i'm not a writer
i'm just telling you stories of my life
the way they come up that i don't have
big words
you don't see anything big in there
but
it's the way i talk
that's the only way i know how to write
i'm not right to him
to impress anybody
with my verbiage
the stories themselves are impressive
enough the the verbiage is secondary
the stories are amazing in here
yeah
another thing that you did
was
take
an honor flight and the honor flight is
a non-profit organization great people
and they provide their their their
mission is to
provide veterans with honor and closure
and so
they fly veterans to washington dc
um
to to see the war memorials and your
name
came up on there
and so you ended up going to washington
dc
thanks to the private donations to the
op to the honor flight organization it
was a great organization like i said
and you said this
when you got there um
i was ticked off because they took so
long to complete the world war ii
memorial only opening in 2004.
by that time most of the men from the
war were gone and will never have the
chance to see it carlin convinced me
that i should go
in their memory so that's why i went
the irony is that the 135th infantry
which is part of the 34th division has a
shield that says to the last man
i was 15 years old the first time i saw
that
well
they are all gone except me
who would ever imagine that i would
actually be
the last man
i got that shield right here on my
jacket
uh
and then
came the battle of the bulge 75th
anniversary
and and there's a guy named mitch
mendler oh
firefighter paramedic here right here in
san diego as a matter of fact
it was him last night and he's the
president of a non-profit organization
called world memorials
and doing great work with that
and they volunteered to sponsor you to
get you out to the to the 75th
anniversary of
the battle the bulge
and um
you say here when we went to the airport
flew down to los angeles i was met at
the gate by my sponsor group who
introduced me
to two of the men entrusted to travel
with me
colonel mike droll of the arizona
rangers and rick cochran the executive
director hispanic medal of honor
joshua kaufman
a holocaust survivor who survived five
concentration camps was amongst the
group
when u.s troops liberated him at the age
of 16 he weighed a mere 55 pounds
his daughter interpreted it for
him in yiddish informing him that i was
going back for d-day
when she communicated that i was the
only one left in my company
he joshua kaufman
got down on his hands and knees and
kissed my feet
that choked me up
he got up
and grabbed my hand
and said love you
and squeezed my hand
we were both crying
that's some
incredible uh you know
they mentioned closure
actually meeting
an individual that had been in the
concentration camps and was liberated by
americans such as yourself
that's
amazing
that only seven years difference in my
life
i was 22.
when that happened
you know i've i've read a bunch of this
book so far um tonight and
i know we've been talking for a while
but i wanted to close the book out with
this this last section that i'll read
and again if
there's so much more in this book i've
only cut covered a couple of the
highlights but there's
it was hard to even select which
highlights to cover because it's all
just incredible stories
but i wanted to close with this quote
here
it says it's mind-boggling to have
someone kiss your feet and thanks for
what those soldiers did
i am not the one to be kissed
i'm representing all the guys who freed
all the concentration camp victims
it was their actions
i'm not a hero i'm here too
i'm here to tell you what i went through
all these people are gone and i'm left
alone
i can't see where i deserve the credit
for that
i'm the last one alive to represent
these guys
that gave their lives over there
so i could really relate this story
to everyone
and again
the the story
is incredible you know uh
you lived it and you're sitting across
the table from me and you even realize
how incredible and almost unbelievable
it is and you are doing an outstanding
job
carrying on and passing on the story
of
your your brothers your comrades in arms
they're the heroes they're the heroes
and and so you're carrying on that story
and that's not the end of the story by
the way because like you said earlier
you're very popular on social media
you're a tick tock star
you're on instagram you're on youtube
it's all under the same title
which is story time with papa jake you
have
hundreds of thousands of followers and
you have millions of views on some of
your stories
of course this book but it's just uh
it's incredible and the story's not over
yet well i hope it is
i hope it isn't for for a while
but uh
how did it start with the tick tock
thing
my granddaughter i told you i raised
since that's
three years old
dances on a cruise ship
coronavirus came
cree cruise ships
quit
she came home
she's a
a very special person to to to her
grandpa and
she
she came over one more one morning and
sat there she says
papa i put you on tick-tock with me
what in the hell is tick-tock
tick-tock she says
it's
a radio thing she says
and
i said what did you put me on tick tock
she says
well
while you were talking to me about one
of your
things happening i i i recorded it and
put it on tick-tock
end of the week she came over she's papa
i'm taking you taking you off of my
tick tock
and putting you on your own wha what are
you doing that for
that
my god leave it alone
i said you're opening a can of worms
here
she says
papa
i it took me seven months to get ten
thousand viewers
seven months she says
you surpassed me in one week
i i said
what does that mean she says
it means that people like to hear you
tell stories
so that's where i'm
at right now
well it's an amazing story um and you're
on you're not just on tick tock you're
on instagram there's a youtube channel
uh that people can if people don't have
tech talk they can watch it on youtube
they can watch it on instagram
uh they can even google me and get a
response it's crazy
the book is called the luckiest man in
the world it's a fantastic read it's
just it's it's an unbelievable story and
if it wasn't
if we weren't sitting here talking to
the man himself you'd have a hard time
believing it but but there he is
and so so definitely um pick up the book
and and it's just incredible um
echo
yes sir do you have any questions at
this time i do not have any questions at
this time thank you sir no echo usually
asks like some kind of interesting
question at the end but maybe today we
didn't just you know we covered it i'm
surprised he he cause i'm surprised i
thought you're gonna ask farming
questions okay i thought you're gonna
talk about chickens or horses no no no
or something like that nothing pretty
straightforward i think at this time
papa jake's papa jake larson
um we've had you for two hours right now
i i want to be respectful of your time
but if there's any other final thoughts
you want to share
amazon is the printer of my book
so uh
and make sure you mention my name there
is another book called the luckiest man
in the world
was found out by because
somebody ordered that book and
the long book came to him so are we
gonna have to have a contest between you
two to see if he's
but
i want to thank you for
for the honor of sitting here
it is an honor for me
because i think by by telling this story
you will
more honor those who gave their lives
for me to be here
that i would not be here without those
guys
that sacrificed themselves
for for me
there is a god
that's my final word
well sir
thank you so much for joining us today
thanks for your family to get for
getting us down here our friend jack
that connected us
um
thanks for being here and and thanks for
sharing your wisdom but
most important thank you for your
service to this great nation
you
and your friends and your generation
stood against tyranny and evil
and allow us
to live under this blessing of freedom
today so we thank you and all your
brothers in arms
well thank you sir for for allowing me
to do this
and i appreciate
very much
what you're doing for me
well we are grateful grateful for you
and grateful for your service and
sacrifice
and the service and sacrifice of all of
your comrades in arms and and especially
as you have mentioned the real heroes
that did not come home they're they're
the ones
god bless them all
indeed sir thank you
and with that
papa jake larson
has left the building
and
clearly um an honor to be able to have
him on
and hear those stories
[Music]
and you know
talking to him before and after man you
know he he kept saying he doesn't have
any pain and and he's doing great
he's doing great
because
you know during the podcast we weren't
we're not really yucking it up or
cracking jokes but we're downstairs he's
we're cracking jokes and even before the
podcast started i he said something
about me
like he he took a shot at me
and i went right back at him talking
about being bald and he's like
laughing and he's just totally sharp
um
man just an honor to be able to have him
on here and
i you didn't have any questions that was
kind of surprising to me no like my i i
was wondering
and actually now like kind of thinking
about thinking about it more let's say
clearly or whatever um
you always kind of wonder about the
experience from
whether it be in the boat
you know landing
and then going on he did you know he
talked about it kind of
for like a better term kind of vaguely
where it'd be like yeah i'm dodging
bullets yeah i'm running i'm running
trying to get away whatever that was
sort of it it wasn't like a
like a narrative like of
boom landing like what happened you know
i'm thinking save it private saving
private right and all this stuff you
don't hear that you know because there
was a lot of reflections saving private
by the way for sure it's freaking d-day
yeah
the shakes like that thing um there was
another one too oh when he went and when
he was looking for a match right for
cigarettes and then he goes oh hey you
got a match he didn't say you got a
match on steven perry ryan but but he
does he was like hey something and he
looks boom okay no face yup boom
that's crazy yeah
the book and the book
has more details
and and you know it's it's
there's a balance right of
wanting to read some of the book and
then getting some of his reflections on
what he went through so
um but just it's just awesome to have
someone like that i mean literally
to go
from d-day
to the battle of the bulge is crazy
it's crazy
and
you know he has this jacket which i'll
post on on the interwebs or whatever but
it has all the little campaigns that he
was in this you know d-day st low go
going right down paris
i kind of rattled them off you know but
it's just um it's unbelievable it's an
honor obviously a ton to learn and a ton
to reflect on
so
thanks uh thanks jack out there in the
in the
in the world who put this together one
of our jiu jitsu bros
made the connection
told you told you we could possibly you
know get in touch with him and then you
were kind enough to respond to him seven
months after he initiated his initial
you know email which was good
we like that
timing and stuff
but
um
what
when i walk away from this i just think
to myself you know as as papa jake kept
saying
you know all these all these other
individuals that didn't make it you know
he's looking at that gravestone thinking
this guy didn't get to have the family
the life
and
he did get to have that chance and guess
what so do we so it seems like we should
be doing our best
to live a life that is worthy of those
sacrifices seems like a good plan
yeah it's it's crazy to to think you
know now being the age that we are
to think like how he mentioned his
friend in the air force who died at like
19 years old that's not even half your
life goal that's like you're
technically you're not even a full adult
really and just that's you know that's
the end
i guess you're a full adult if you're in
hope minnesota because you're up at
you're six years old milking 32 cows
every morning at night oh yeah
yeah that's really it's so cool to read
that stuff it's cool to read that stuff
in the book for sure what it was like
living back then
they didn't have electricity he they
didn't have electricity in their house
until he got out of the service in 1945.
that's crazy we have 45. he's all like
oh that was a big jump from the horse
and buggy yep
yep that was life we think we think like
oh i went from a you know a v6 to a v8
whoa that was amazing change and i'm so
much better off now got that gps now
yeah i got that gps system
they're in horse and buggy what about
what about this whole scenario
well you know my school is 14 miles away
and in the winter time the only way to
get there is by horse and slay
slay yeah man and by the way another
thing they don't they're not wearing
gore-tex
thinsulate freaking you know pile
polyester they're in wool
at best
some canvas jacket right yeah just a
different time different time freaking
epic it's crazy how he uh you know he's
color blind like all this stuff and then
he falls in he didn't say how he felt
down that was the question i should ask
like why do you fall down like how do
you feel just randomly he tripped over a
curb okay so you know a parking curb yes
sir he tripped over one of those he was
just like looking off ahead and just hit
it boom hits his head color blindness
cured and what else is curious
the colorblindness was cured when he got
cataract surgery oh
there's a section in the book called
medical miracles or something like that
and it covers all these things he
mentioned some of them yeah his shakes
got cur
cured when he got hit in the head okay
so you're yeah you're the correct
generation okay you remember nintendo
entertainment system the original nes i
i remember it but i don't i remember
that it was a thing but it's not
something that i had it wasn't your gym
all right you mean because we didn't
have electricity in my house
so no we we didn't have
any
money for that kind of thing
but
i that might be too strong
my dad was like a computer he was into
computers before computers were really a
thing and so he had
old school computers yeah but because
you have an old school computer you're
not getting some game system
yeah so he was and plus he thought that
a computer was for computing right not
for playing a game good job so there was
no
we never had any of those systems now we
have one game playing system but we did
have a computer do you know do you know
about old old-school computers i do yeah
do you know what a commodore vic 20 is
well you know that model specifically
you know it's the first one okay
commodore for the first model
i want to say that the
embed the memory that came with the
machine itself
was
2k
and then there was some cartridge that
you plugged in that gave you an extra 4k
yeah yeah this computer was weak yes
very weak either way
attorney
so you didn't even have atari then no no
atari nope no it's hard brutal it's kind
of abusive and eventually we had
we had
like versions of the games that were on
atari
but instead of it being called pac-man
it was a generic version called like
snack man
you know what i'm saying because my dad
yes sir my dad was a cheap human i
understand
you're not spending money on anything
this was when you get he was part of
like a sharing group where they would
trade cassette tapes that had this
information on it that you could play
the game yeah so we're talking just okay
so okay
this might not be horse and buggy but i
understand absolutely yep
you lived on a dirt road too so hey man
i get it
um well either way the the rest of the
99.9 of us that got our nintendo
entertainment system know that there's
when you're in when nintendo got kind of
older
and it would jam up right you put the
game in you stuff it down and it and it
it blinks or what it doesn't turn on so
there's two two methods to get it going
everyone knows the the one you take the
game out you blow it you blow on it
because there might be dust in there i
don't know i think it's psychological
either way now you put it back in it
usually works second method is
you turn it off and you hit the side of
the thing you hit it just like a even
like a tv
yeah oh yeah we do it all the time um tv
is kind of like that too i think
that's what papa jake's head was
you hit his head boom shake's gone you
see him saying
maybe they should have blew in his eyes
or something
maybe that would have worked i'm just
saying
nintendo papa jake these lessons are
everywhere lessons are everywhere but um
you know what is incredible is he he is
real just incredibly sharp
and healthy walking up and down the
stairs no factor yeah just awesome um
makes me think about health you know
mental and physical health yeah
how we can try and maintain that as long
as possible yeah it's true all right
well we got some solutions to that look
at that segway
oh i kind of threw you a nice little
softball you're just rolling
well hey we're working out yeah right
we're shooting if i don't make us let's
face it if there's no if there's not a
segway we're talking about we i mean we
were just talking about commodore vic
20s
right we were way off base well so if
there's no segway to get us back you
know who knows what's happening and
you're correct so segway occurred now
we're we're back on track yeah back into
the workouts right bob jake is 120
pounds see that's another thing you got
to remember where it's not like it's
like
freaking jocko rolling up through you
know you know how you guys talk about
like all the gear that you guys carry or
whatever it's like bro 120 carrying gear
that's like some effort well he said he
had 75 pounds of gear plus his weapon
so we're talking
that's a massive amount that's the over
double body weight yeah now i did i can
tell you that guys nowadays carry way
more gear than they did back then yeah
for the most for the most part
especially like in nam
in nam
you were just carrying two k well let me
let me get more specific here the seals
in vietnam
one canteen
four grenades a bunch of mags and your
weapon like those guys rolled light
light
and nowadays man you're going you got
radios you got
so much ammo you got body armor you got
helmet you got night visions you got
lasers you got extra batteries for
everything it's just a lot more yeah
which is not good by the way in many
cases so makes sense either way when
you're 120 yeah bro
you better be going extra light
otherwise that's gonna take some effort
so nonetheless
that's neither here nor nor there as far
as right now
right now we're trying to be as strong
as we can i don't care 120 180 190. two
bills whatever
we're trying to be as strong as we can
over here and as smart as we can all
this stuff right yes not all of us are
going to reach 99 by the way hey this is
just the reality of the situation but
we're going to try cool
so we got to do good stuff for our minds
and our body
don't worry we got you don't worry
chocolate supplements yeah we got you
including energy drinks sure we all know
about it but we're gonna go over it okay
energy drinks with sugar bad i'm
simplified bad energy drinks
with preservatives and poisons bad
energy drinks without preservatives and
poisons good as long as there's no sugar
good okay perfect
chocolate discipline go energy drink
sweetened with monk fruit fruit natural
no preservatives pasteurized an actual
healthy energy drink bacopa alpha gpc
these are good things for you literally
good for you literally but what about
the what about the downside
i i have yet to find a downside at all
oh wait there's no downside oh yeah when
you run out i can't sit down we have to
be watching out for downsides what can
be the downside i can tell you what the
downside is possibly
if you drink it too late in the
afternoon you might not go to sleep very
early very well yeah you can actually
put yourself into a tough situation if
you have one at let's say six o'clock at
seven o'clock at night yeah and let's
and here's the thing there's a
disclaimer with that too because that
depends on your tolerance for caffeine
true so you gotta have kind of be
sensitive to it to actually have that
problem because it's only 95 milligrams
it's like a regular it's actually not
even that big of a proper coffee it's
like a
regular like cup cup does anyone drink
one cup of coffee anymore i don't know
yeah i don't think so not that i know
but i don't know either way nonetheless
nonetheless as they say nonetheless it
does have a little bit caffeine for the
little little boost but all the other
good stuff is a healthy thing
i was in uh hawaii kauai my homeland
yeah we were and i was talking to my dad
my dad's 75.
so i'm telling him about him about my
energy drink but fit like kinda in the
beginning i was like this is not going
to be right i'm saying jacob has an
energy drink but i'm not the only one at
this table that has an energy drink true
and i'm preaching it because there's an
echo charles energy drink
and i'm preaching it but at first i'm
like man why am i even telling you about
to see some fight not gonna drink energy
drinks but then i'm thinking wait yeah
he can he can straight up drink this
energy drink and be good good to go
so yeah bc that's a bc yup a wise man
so you can get that you can get many
different flavors you mentioned mine
mine is mango the best bro ask around
it's the best
interesting maybe not conceptually
nonetheless if you don't like the mango
there's all kinds of other flavors too
sour up sniper orange all this stuff
look into it
chocofuel.com so you can get the stuff
also for your joint spread
uh papa jake's talking about his joints
don't even hurt no
okay that's how i want to be yeah that's
insane and currently that's how i am my
joints don't hurt either see i'm saying
it's because of the joint warfare and
the super krill oil i didn't bring any
in hawaii
did you feel it how long how many days
did it take before you felt that four
four days four days yeah it could have
been really bad i was sleeping on didn't
help either but it wasn't one time i
felt it in my knee though that's not a
bed bro yeah no the bed cannot make you
more sure i think plus you got the loose
knees the loose skinny knees
whatever i was doing squats too though
squats on vacation i'm just saying yeah
you want to stay in the game
when you travel or just general life
know protect yourself immune wise
vitamin d d3 you can get that you can
get cold war
i just had to jack some cold war up yeah
right now because you know you get that
little
to me when i feel that like where's that
cold war started hitting it hard molk
by the way yeah we're just having a
discussion
uh
and
look we all know that you have your
favorite yes sir which is fine you might
maybe your favorites peanut butter
strawberry whatever
that's cool
the fact is
after a month
it's good to have that alternate
alternate
opportunity to get into something you
know it's good to have that ultimate
opportunity to get into some men
get into some vanilla get into some
chocolate get into some banana cream
which is out now by the way have you had
the banana cream yet i have
been lucky enough to have the
opportunity to have banana bomber and
your assessment is
well i didn't taste it yet okay just
came in like it came in while i was gone
and i opened it i have
i have a very strong
uh assessment team
sure to taste things it's my family sure
because they don't care about anything
yes they will smack me with whatever
and banana bomber
boom
five stars across the board okay which
is legit
because they will look like i said
they have no issue with telling me if
something sucks yeah they'll be all into
it and plus they're also into stuff
is it a thing
okay i am you know what you know what a
foodie is
yesterday i do yeah right it's a thing
yeah it's a thing and i think it's more
of a thing now than it ever was like
when we were younger yeah there wasn't a
thing
no one would ever say i'm really into
food they wouldn't even say that
there was no thing like that yeah it's
just like food
it's like wine taster right like i'm
into wine tasting but instead of wine is
food
i think so i think people kids younger
people these days have more
more appreciation and sensitivity to
taste yeah
so because i'm kind of like
i'll
if i can stomach it it tastes good
straight up insensitive
entertainment if i can stomach it it
tastes good if i can't then it's not
good right those are pretty binary
my kids man they're freaking
so when they start getting kind of hyped
about something i know it's good so no
banana bomber yeah and bananas one of
those and i don't know maybe i'm alone
on this but maybe i'm not banana is the
kind where it's like okay but it's good
it's fine it's fine but let's say you
know when you got your more exotic
fruits
you don't want to ruin it but you
usually add bananas sometimes oddly yes
yeah and that that's not normal we got
to send some to tulsi because tulsi is
kind of the original banana adder right
sure she had that she had the specific
method yeah they're very innovative yeah
right for sure she's always on top of
things she's just out ahead of the curve
in the game she's got an open mind and
she looks and she assesses and she comes
up with a solution set you got the
frozen banana you're right so frozen
rotten banana is it rotten uh we'll say
extremely right yeah sure but but the
banana okay so oddly bananas like
whatever
we should have made the signature flavor
for tulsi banana oh yeah frozen banana
sure yeah but um it's like cucumber
where it's like cool cucumber is fine
but if you get something that's like way
better than cucumber then you add
cucumber cucumber makes it go to the
middle of the road with it so it kind of
brings it down
that's the nature of cucumbers and
that's the nature of bananas too from
into a fancy uh hotel where they have
water and there's cucumbers in the water
yes sir do you like that
i i like i like the effort for sure but
i like the lemons like better
yeah pineapple all day
okay so cucumbers to me
bring me some plain water honestly you
know they tried the cucumber gatorade
too remember back when i was young and
younger than i am now but cucumber
gatorade no no correct you're you're
who's the freaking idiot on the
marketing crew that was like hey let's
make cucumber gatorade i i don't know
he fired
but surprisingly so the point is with
the banana surprisingly and actually not
so surprisingly so i like banana okay
cool fine but it brings things to banana
level if it's better than banana which
is a bad thing but you go banana cream
you're a banana cream pie yeah yeah yeah
freaking legit it's almost like it kind
of supersedes it transcends the banana
stigma
i'm over here just here to tell you i'm
just here to tell you and this banana
cream this is what i expected i didn't
taste it yeah but this is what i expect
that's what i expect with the banana
cream you know what's interesting about
this you can tell you've been gone for a
while because you and i are talking to
go
and it's also funny because you'd think
maybe we had something you know
interesting to talk about yeah in a
broad sense no we're literally talking
about cucumbers and bananas which is
jacked up
we're hurting people's lives right now
we're taking time away from them so
check it out get mulk you get this stuff
from jackalful.com you can get it you
get the drinks at wawa you can get
everything at the vitamin shop go get
that stuff up
go get it and by the way jackalful.com
if you subscribe to any of these things
you get the shipping for free that way
we compete with the
large global corporations
that are trying to take over the world
that's true help us compete go subscribe
yeah man it's true we can help you stay
healthy you know speaking of large
global well corporations taking over the
world you know how they you know use you
know what what what they do is they do
this mass thing where they get the labor
for as cheap as they can yep they get it
free if they they can they will try for
sure yeah if they can see it doesn't
work like that it's not sustainable you
see insane
unlike origin see that is sustainable
i'll tell you why it's all made in
america everything all their stuff their
denim jeans got jiu jitsu stuff you got
boots wallets what uh is there belts i
got a belt belts wallets
beanies sweatshirts shorts oh yeah
pants and we got more stuff coming oh
yeah we got the hunt line coming which
the hunt line gonna be versatile too
yeah i was talking to pete i'm like hey
you know like the puffy jackets sure
that everyone wears
every a lot of people wear sure not
super puffy but like a thin puff yeah
yeah like when you go snowboarding yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
but
that kind of thing
when you go anywhere cold people are
wearing that all everywhere right i said
hey we need that well let's we're on
that so we're gonna be able to have
an american made one because these
people are like oh well you know we
support the environment we give some of
our um
some of our
our one percent of our profits to the
environmental causes oh cool meanwhile
you're supporting a freaking factory in
china that's putting more crap into the
air than your one percent could ever
cover
and by the way the people that are
breathing that in is not just the people
that live there it's also worldwide and
the slave labor that they have making
these things so we get it you want to
you want to say how nice you are we get
it you want to talk about your
how positive you're doing for the
environment yeah
you're
not telling the truth
so we're we're gonna we're gonna we got
you covered origin usa so there's an
expression ptn
right ptn stands for better than nothing
right so people use that in a good way
like it's right it's better than nothing
right yeah you think workouts freaking
um paying attention to your kids uh like
all this stuff you can use btn the btn
method hey it's better than nothing it's
like looking at the bright side of
things which is it's not all bad you see
i'm saying
that's what makes it a tricky thing but
let's face it you really want to go
what do you how did you do it the low
res the freaking black real black and
white
right btn is not good you want to do the
best you can straight up yeah all right
so you start giving one percent to
something that is a
percent detriment yeah that's btn that's
bad yeah you see him saying it's better
than nothing true yeah it's also 49 bad
freaking savages so origin usa supply
chain taking care of
american made taken care of taken care
of american economy being stimulated
taken care of taking care of jobs being
created yes sir good job environment
being saved good job you talk to all
our people there making stuff bro
they'll tell you all about it smiling
the whole time yeah oh man i'm here to
tell you original usa dot com dot com
that's you can get yourself something
also chocolate store called jocko store
chocolatestore.com that's where you can
get your discipline equals freedom
shirts hats hoodies that kind of cool
stuff uh stuff this is good
it's one you want to represent and we're
representing
on this path
you know what decentralized command is
yes sir okay so sometimes is there such
a thing as too much decentralized
command yes sir so
the
there happens to be warrior kid soap
we're down with that right young aiden
out there decentralized command making
stuff happen yeah guess what else he
made
oh yeah candles
so it's funny because in my house
i don't like candles
yeah i don't like the smell of them i
don't like the more heat being produced
in my house i don't like a fire hazard
up in here
right i don't like the the uh the uh the
uh
what's that word the atmosphere that it
gives off right
yeah right you want to make fire we'll
make a fire we're good with that a
candle yes sir no we're not happening
but decentralized command all of a
sudden we got a jackal candle and
apparently we have an echo candle yes
sir yeah so that's out there and echo
soap too by the way
so you know hey man do your thing it
sounds good yeah dtn yeah yeah yeah
in a good way this time um but yeah
there's good stuff on there taco store
also on jocko's store
sure the shirt locker a lot of updates
to that one upgrades upgrade update
sounds like you know just maybe just you
know some bad things that are now not
bad i like the way you take your ideas
and post them on the world
it's kind of funny how you do that i'm
trying to help over here you seem saying
either way upgrades on the shirt locker
check those out shirt locker if you
don't know what that is that's a new
shirt every month subscription situation
every month they're all cool they're
they're a little bit more creative you
know you know what jack daniel does
oh yeah well no he gets the he's he has
enough shirts right oh yeah he's pretty
common in america you have enough shirts
yes sir but he still wants us a porch
and he's seen some shirts that have come
out where he's been like that one would
have been nice yeah so he gif he gets
them and then he gifts them to the
appropriate person right yeah that makes
sense dean fully jd
making it happen uh subscribe to the
podcast speaking of subscriptions
wherever you subscribe to podcast we
were just talking about podcast reviews
yeah it's cool you want to leave a
review it's cool what's interesting
about the reviews is they're permanent
on the apple reviews they're permanent
so you can go back in time
and you can go read early reviews about
echo charles man the world was a
ruthless place that is totally it was
totally my fault i i you know i got what
do you call i i started on the wrong
foot what's that expression you know it
got off on the wrong foot this is why my
first analogy if i remember correctly
was like you know you got to balance the
dichotomies or whatever you were talking
about back then and i made the analogy
of a
glob of mercury
on a trash can lid oh that's right and
bro i'm just saying imagine that try to
balance it it's the same thing it's a
perfect analogy when you think about it
it's just kind of kind of out from
[__] left field or whatever
and i get it yeah i took heat for it
yeah
you took some heavies in the early days
doing better now
k-dog was on the other day he got his
first taste of uh social media you know
attacks
so anyways subscribe to this check out
jocko unraveling and recording another
one tomorrow so those should be up
hitting some pretty interesting uh
topics with my brother daryl cooper
grounded podcast
the warrior kid podcast and we have
jocko underground
jockowinderground.com this is our
alternative platform in case we get
attacked banned
shadow band which apparently is a thing
now which has happened have you been
shadow banned i i don't think i'm
that influential
and you never know
maybe i need to take over your page and
start posting all my controversial stuff
oh yeah that's so controversial um
well it is interesting you know it is
interesting but
you wouldn't think that there'd be
anything that they would look at me and
go yeah we need to suppress this guy but
hey here we are literally being
suppressed yeah so we have to have a
backup plan we have to have a
contingency plan in place so that's why
we have jocko underground.com
if you want to help us
build and maintain that it costs 18.8
dollars and 18 cents a month
that helps us build it and maintain it
we give you back another additional
podcast do you need more podcasts
probably not
maybe not but maybe you like to chill
maybe you like to hear about some
alternative topics and maybe you just
want to support either way we appreciate
it also if you can't support us we'll
support you if you can't afford eight
dollars and eighteen cents a month it's
cool email assistance at
jockleunderground.com
we have a youtube channel it's true
which
there's some really good videos on there
and most of the really good videos have
that extra little component that extra
thing that just makes them hit
yes sir and that thing usually comes
from me
the assistant director
it's true yeah i had to well when carrie
was in the hot seat k-dog i had to kind
of i had to go a little bit deep on that
one
yeah you've uh
you've embraced that role quite nicely
and we're happy we're happy with that
that's just the way it works yes sir so
subscribe to the youtube channel check
out the videos
also you can you can see what papa jake
looks like
and 99 years now you're getting it 99
years old impressive also psychological
warfare it's an album we did back in the
day
very useful album gets us past our
moments of weakness
do you ever think about and i'm not
saying you jock i'm saying to our people
you ever think about the day where
you're about to slip or you're about to
skip the workout what if jocko is like
right there not yelling not yelling by
the way just telling you hey like hey
let's not skip this workout in fact
here's some good reasons why you
shouldn't skip this workout so i'm
saying and he was just telling you
practic practical advice
to not skip the workout you probably do
the workout you probably do the workout
and in fact you will do the workout
that's what psychological warfare is
straight up
so you get that you get that wherever
you get mp3s it's a good one also if you
want to hang something awesome on your
wall go to flipsidecanvas.com
which is dakota meyer's company and he
makes awesome stuff to hang on your wall
that's what it is made in america got
some books obviously first book luckiest
man in the world
stories from the life of papa jake by by
jake larson
it's a great book we skim the surface
today go check it out support the man
himself also final spin
had that story come out
had that book come out
and
check that one out if you want to check
that one out um
i would recommend you don't read it on a
plane like jp danelle if you're gonna
get embarrassed when you're crying i'm
not saying you're gonna cry but i'm
saying
it's an emotional book it's an emotional
rollercoaster so check that out there's
some lessons in there
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual the code the evaluation the
protocol discipline equals freedom field
manual way of the warrior kid one two
three four christmas is coming
i don't care what you could you could be
a billionaire you can't get a kid a
better gift than those four books that
is a fact there's nothing you can get a
kid
that you know
better than those books nothing nothing
there's nothing better that's a bold
statement and i just said it and i and i
stand by 100 there's nothing that could
have better influence on a kid than
those four books when okay do you
remember the date that part one where
the warrior kid came out i want to say
2016. okay 16 so we got what five years
in the in the bank
maybe a little bit more than five years
my daughter was eight now
still
demands i read
every single night
part one we just finished it again by
the way yeah
just the best gift you can give for a
kid
so hook that up also miking the dragons
for the little kids best little kids
book that's ever been written so that's
what i've been hearing a lot of
uh you know when
dads
post and say they have a hard time
making it through the book without
tearing up
that's where we're at yeah if you let it
for sure yeah that's kind of where we're
at uh
about face by hackworth and then extreme
ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership
also we have echelon front which is a
leadership consultancy we
solve problems through leadership
leadership is the solution if you need
help with the leadership inside your
organization go to echelonfront.com you
can also find out about our live events
there
whether it's
the muster whether it's field training
exercises ef battlefield
you can check that out next muster is in
dallas texas by the way march 24th and
25th we have online training program
you can't get good at jiu jitsu
in one day you can't get good at
basketball one day you can't get a good
guitar in one day you can't get good at
leadership in one day you also can't get
good at leadership from reading one book
one time and thinking you got it now it
doesn't work like that that's why we
made the extreme ownership academy if
you want to come you want to ask
questions you want to interact with me
with life with the rest of the ef team
come on there extreme ownership.com and
if you want to help service members
active and retired their families gold
star families check out mark lee's mom
mama lee she's got a charity
organization
and if you want to donate or you want to
get involved
you want to help veterans
go to americasmightywarriors.org
and if you want
more of my
over-emotional episodes or you need more
of echo's exasperating explorations
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter on the gram and on facebook
facebook
echoes that echo charles i am at jocko
willink and don't forget that you can
also check out story time with papa jake
on instagram on tick tock tick tock on
youtube
great
great stuff to watch
and to all the service men and women
past present and future
thank you and especially to those of you
that served in world war ii
whether you're here with us in this life
or you've moved on to the next
we will not forget what you did for us
and for
mankind
and to our police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers
border patrol secret service and all the
first responders out there thank you for
your service which keeps us safe here on
the home front
and everyone else out there
this life is a gift
it's a gift and i'll tell you something
else it is a fleeting gift
and every day that we have is one
day
closer to death and as papa jake said
you can't turn back time
you cannot turn back time and in the end
even forever is too short
so
follow the example
of this brave man that we heard from
today
jake larson and live every day
to the utmost and you do that
by going out there
and getting after it
until next time this is echo and jocko
out